طب مات الغربيه تنافق في شعوبها وتتكلم عن
النهايه كافه الارهابي الذي كافه الارهاب
المخابرات القذافي عبد الله السنوسي كاد
ان يلاقي نفس مصير زميله السابق محمد ابو
عجيل مسعود الذي يقبع الان وراء القضبان
في الولايه المتحده بانتظار محاكمته عن
قضيه اسقاط طائره ركاب امريكيه فوق قريه
لقرب الاسكتلنديه ما ادى الى مقتل 270
شخصا عام
وكانت حكومه الدبيبه المنتهيه صلاحيتها قد
سلمته لواشنطن بعد اختطافه وحجزه من قبل
ميليشيه اشرفت على تسليمه لمسؤولين
امريكيين اما السنوسي الذي تعتبره امريكا
المسؤول الاول عن كارثه لوكربي والذي حكم
بالاعدام في عام 2015
لارتكابه جرائم ضد ليبيين معارضين لنظام
القذافي فهو حاليا مسجون في ليبيا
اضافه الى ملف لقربي ارتبط اسمه عبد الله
السنوسي بعده جرائم منها قتل 1100 شخصا من
النزلاء في سجن ابو سليم عام
وتفجير طائره ركاب فوق النيجر ادت الى
مصرع 170 شخصا عام 1989
وكانت الاداره الامريكيه السابقه ابان
رئاسه دونالد ترامب بدات المفاوضات مع
طرابلس لكن لم تصل الى نتيجه الا بعد
انقضاء صلاحيه حكومه الدبيبه والتي يبدو
انها سلمت ابو عجيله لمحاوله كسب دعم
واشنطن مسؤولون ليبيون صرحوا لصحيفه
الجاردن البريطانيا ان تسليم محمد ابو
عجيل مسعود تسبب في موجه من الاستنكار في
الاوساط الشعبيه الامر الذي دفع الدبابه
الى التراجع عن تسليم السنوسي
لكن ليس من المعروف اذا كان هذا تراجع
النهائيا ام محاوله الاستيعاب الغضب داخل
ليبيا انس نماسي العربيه